everybody has to wake up everyday and
make a decision in every situation you
can either choose to look at it
negatively or you can choose to try to
find the good and say [ __ ] it I should
be able to be happy it's a really
interesting question
I felt like life handed me an extremely
unfair set of cards my gender at birth
was female but I knew for sure that I
was a man I was the boy with no legs
I was unfulfilled I struggled with PTSD
I was told I have cancer
I felt like my best was a failure I was
telling myself that I wasn't enough I
locked myself away I felt voiceless
trapped extremely angry I let the
opinions of other people literally
dictate how I felt and I asked myself
why I just knew in that moment something
has to change and everything just hit me
it's like [ __ ] I should be able to be
happy and I started looking into myself
and in that one specific moment I was
able to find my confidence in myself
taking control my life was a rebirth
setting all that baggage was complete
freedom I was putting trust in me and
how I was gonna fulfill my life that was
my time where I kind of realized that
you know I got something to prove I felt
really empowered invincible alive
all of a sudden I wasn't the victim
anymore I would be the Victoire now I am
an online fitness coach of cancer free I
use cooking as a therapy I am a
transgender activist I've won two gold
to silver and a bronze medal at the
Paralympic Games I'm doing something
that I love for living life is not easy
why feed something that's already so
negative in my life with more negativity
you had control over that there are no
excuses over there's no no in the
equation there's no camps and the
equation is always a way it's a
responsibility to yourself your
happiness is a choice away use it as an
opportunity to write the next chapter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]